Tenemos esta ecuación aquí, y lo que quiero
que hagas es pausar este video y ver si puedes
resolverla. ¿Qué valores de x satisfacen la
ecuación? Muy bien, ahora trabajemos juntos
en esto. Una técnica podría ser simplemente
tratar de completar el cuadrado aquí, en el lado
izquierdo. Para hacer eso, permíteme escribirlo
de esta manera: x² - 8x y luego escribiré el + 1
aquí es igual a 85. Ahora, si quiero completar el
cuadrado sólo tengo que pensar ¿qué puedo agregar
a ambos lados de esta expresión para hacer que el
lado izquierdo sea un cuadrado perfecto? Bueno,
si miro este coeficiente de 8 negativo del primer término,podría decir: Bien, permíteme tomar la mitad del
8 negativo, eso sería 4 negativo, y luego 4 negativo al cuadrado será 16 positivo,así que pondré 16 positivo en el lado izquierdo,
y además puedo restar 16 del lado izquierdo, o lo
puedo sumar en el lado derecho. Ten en cuenta que
acabo de hacer lo mismo en ambos lados de esta
ecuación. Y esto ¿para qué nos sirve? Bueno,
pues ahora lo que acabo de poner entre paréntesis
es un cuadrado perfecto, esto es lo mismo que
(x - 4)²; lo hice a propósito: nos fijamos
en este 8 negativo, la mitad de eso es 4 negativo, lo elevas
al cuadrado y obtienes 16, y puedes verificar
que (x - 4) (x - 4) es de hecho igual a esto,
y luego tenemos + 1, y esto será igual a, ¿qué es
85 + 16?, eso es 101. Y ahora queremos deshacernos
de este 1 en el lado izquierdo, y la forma más
fácil de hacerlo es restar 1 de ambos lados,
de esa manera aislamos (x - 4)² y nos quedamos con
(x - 4)², estos se cancelarán igual a 100. Ahora,
si algo al cuadrado es igual a 100, eso significa
que ese algo es igual a la raíz cuadrada positiva
o negativa de 100, o que ese algo (x - 4) es igual
a 10 positivo o negativo. Todo lo que hice fue
sacar la raíz cuadrada positiva o negativa de 100,
y eso tiene sentido porque si tomo 10² positivo
obtendré 100, si tomo 10² negativo obtengo 100, entonces(x - 4 ) podría ser uno de esos. Y ahora sólo
sumó 4 a ambos lados de la ecuación. ¿Qué obtengo?
Obtengo que x = 4 ± 10; puedo escribirlo también
como x = 4 + 10 es 14 y luego 4 - 10 es igual a
6 negativo. Estas son dos formas de resolverlo,
pero hay otras formas de resolver esta ecuación.
Podríamos desde el principio restar 85 de ambos
lados. Algunas personas se sienten más cómodas
resolviendo cuadráticas si la expresión cuadrática
es igual a 0, y si hiciéramos eso obtendríamos
x² - 8 x - 84 = 0. Todo lo que hice fue restar
85 de ambos lados de esta ecuación para obtener
esto. Ahora podemos abordar esto de dos maneras
diferentes: podemos completar el cuadrado de
nuevo o simplemente podríamos intentar factorizar.
Si completamos el cuadrado veremos algo muy
similar a esto. Voy a resolverlo rápidamente:
si veo esta parte puedo decir x² - 8x y luego
una vez más la mitad de 8 negativo es 4 negativo,
este cuadrado es más 16, y luego tendría menos
84 -permíteme hacer eso en color azul para poder
darle seguimiento-, menos 84, y luego si agrego 16
en el lado izquierdo -podría agregarlo también del
lado derecho para que ambos lados tengan 16 o si
quiero mantener la igualdad podría restar 16 del
lado izquierdo-, así que agrego 16, resto 16; no
he cambiado el valor del lado izquierdo que sería
igual a 0; esta parte de aquí es (x - 4)²; esta
parte de aquí es menos 100 = 0 y luego agregamos
100 a ambos lados y obtenemos exactamente lo
que obtuvimos antes. Ahora veamos otra forma
en que podríamos resolver esto sin completar el
cuadrado. Podríamos decir que x² - 8 x - 84 = 0,
y pensar en cuál par de números al
multiplicarlos nos da 84 negativo,
por lo tanto deben tener signos diferentes, ya
que al multiplicarlos obtengo un número negativo
y que al sumarlos obtengamos un 8 negativo, y allí
podríamos ver la factorización de 84 negativo o de
84 en general. Podría ser, pensando en 84, podría
ser 2 x 42 y obviamente uno de ellos tendría que
ser negativo y uno de ellos tendría que ser
positivo para llegar al 84 negativo, pero la
diferencia entre estos dos números, si uno fuera
positivo y otro negativo, es mucho mayor que 8,
así que esto no funciona. Intentemos, veamos,
haré algunas mentalmente: 3 x 28, esa diferencia
es mayor que 8; 4 x... 4 x 21 tampoco porque la
diferencia entre 4 y 21 sigue siendo mayor que 8;
veamos, 5 no entra en esto; 6 x 14, eso es
interesante. Muy bien, pensemos en esto.
Entonces 6 x 14 = 84, uno de ellos tiene que ser
negativo, y dado que cuando sumamos los números y
obtenemos un número negativo, eso significa que el
más grande es negativo. Veamos: 6 x 14 negativo es
84 negativo, 6 + 14 negativo, es de hecho, igual a
8 negativo. Entonces podemos factorizar esto como
(x + 6) (x - 14) = 0, y entonces el producto de
esas dos cosas es igual a 0, lo que significa que
si cualquiera de ellos es igual a 0 eso haría que
toda la expresión sea igual a 0, así que podemos
decir que x + 6 = 0 o x - 14 = 0, restamos 6 de
ambos lados aquí y nos queda que x = 6 negativo,
o sumamos 14 a ambos lados aquí y nos queda
x = 14, exactamente lo que obtuvimos aquí.